the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
right
and we've done some reviews so
something else
yeah symmetry reviewing principal axes
ideas what else
if we spent quite a bit of time I
generalized sources ways for computing
them all right all right and so and I'm
begin trying to begin to summarize what
we've done up to this point because we
have a quiz coming next Tuesday so some
of yesterday's lecture was intended to
kind of start pulling together comparing
direct versus Lagrangian Vantage's
disadvantages and on Tuesday next we'll
do more examples okay so the problem
you're going to work on today and you
really are going to work in groups and
how many do we have here we got four not
enough for three groups let's say we
have a double pendulum made out of two
now I have two pieces of chart it's got
its two slender rods that an
approximation and this is a double
pendulum they have many that one and
this one have a lot in common
takes how many coordinates to completely
describe the motion
one for each rod right and the
coordinates up there that are drawn in
that diagram is the angle the first one
with with the vertical and the angle of
the second one with the vertical another
F with that you can completely describe
any allowable motion the system so a
double pendulum has a properties that
it's got two natural frequencies and two
mode shapes that's the shape of the
first mode both masses go in the same
direction and the second mode looks like
that two masses go in opposite
directions not with equal amplitudes but
opposite directions and it's a different
frequency - it's higher so that's two
natural frequencies - mode shapes and if
you had if in this case shows a force
acting on the system you know pushing
this thing back and forth and we're
interested in the generalized forces or
thinking in terms of the work done by
the non-conservative forces so the
exercise to do in groups and we won like
four or five of you or a group you five
or a group and you two four five or
group their work this out find this
vector this is a position vector to the
point of application of the force and we
want you to do that actually I did
something last time but I'm almost
forgetting to do it I want to remind you
something professor Gossard each week
for the recitations he teaches the
thirsty ones does a write-up of the
recitation and they're posted so this
week the solution to this problem is
posted but also a little quick review of
the important stuff so this would be
posted and basically I've redrawn it up
here on the board so this is this
kinematic method for obtaining
generalized forces so you're a body with
n forces on it here's the ice one at
each point of application of the force
there is a total virtual displacement
that is basically comes from the sum of
all the individual generalized
coordinate virtual motions some of them
up you get the total and so therefore at
each point each each the applicant of
application of each force there is a
total amount of virtual work that's done
so the total don conservative work is
the sum of the virtual work done at the
point of application of every force
summed over all the forces and remember
inside of here the total displacement at
every location is the summation over of
all the generalized coordinates so it
really ends up as a double sum this dot
product of forces types Delta RI it's a
double summation over the applicant the
forces that are applied and over the
generalized coordinates but at the end
of the day what you end up doing the
calculation you want to do is you need
to know the generalized force the force
associated with each generalized
coordinate and that's the summation of
the contribution of the virtual work
caused by that coordinates motion dotted
into the force at every location so at
every location there's a little
contribution to the total work done and
therefore the total generalized force is
this sum so today's problem is easy or
easy in the sense that there's a as one
you only have to do deal with one force
but this is a little Messier problem and
that you gotta do in order to do this
you need to be able this is the R sub I
in this case there's point P what you
need I want you to first just in groups
work out what this vector is RP in the
system as drawn here is the inertial
system XY generalized coordinates theta
1 theta 2 and this bar is l1
long this barbell too long and come up
with an answer that in a form like this
something in the I hat direction plus
something in the J hat direction and
then as your group finishes this is a
group one here come put your answer up
second group put your answer up third
group with your answer up and we'll move
on this will go pretty fast all right
looks like you're pretty much in
agreement Naaman talked about so let's
do the next piece so the next part is to
compute your variations this part of the
calculation for each of the coordinates
so do RP with respect to theta 1 + RP
with respect to theta 2 and write down
your answers so the last step here is
get q theta 1 q theta 2 so move on to
getting the two generalized forces now
and then if you did that you would have
this would have to be a semi for two
components remember this is a sum just
happens in this example we only have I
goes from 1 to 1 but if there were two
forces then you would do this twice
you'd have an r1 with respect to theta 1
and n r2 with respect to theta 1 and you
do this product twice add the two pieces
together to get the total the total
generalized force is the sum of the bits
that come from all of the individual
forces
yeah so now let's hear let's have a B
and we'll call it just B force and it
has BX components and B Y components you
would now also have to compute and what
would be our B you would find it then
you'd have our B would be this vector
which is just your bat piece plus this
piece right so you'd have just the our B
would be this Plus this and then you
would do derivative of our B with
respect to theta one and you'd get
something and derivative of our B with
respect to theta two
yeah so you have to so this thing would
ended up being the summation of two
contributions right this would look like
an F B dot R B with respect to and you
got to do this is just for just one of
them
so we'll just we'll do the theta one
with respect to theta one plus f I'm
just calling this one F dot our
derivative RP with respect to theta one
so you get two contributions from the
two forces give you the total Q this
would be Q theta one and then you do it
again for the theta two and you'd have
two possible pieces every and every
point of application of a force you
define an R you eventually need to do
this summation for every force alright
everybody's got the same answers so now
I'm going to try it this is an indirect
way of answering your question I'm now
going to try to convince you that you're
wrong
and I want you to tell me why my logic
is flawed okay I look so I look at these
answers here and so this says that if I
this line right here if I caused a
little Delta Theta one here that swings
this arm through that amount and it
moves a distance in the X direction l1
cosine theta Delta Theta one and it
moves over that little bit
right here right okay and you're telling
me that that this point over here moves
that amount the point of application of
this force due to Delta X Delta Theta
one is this Delta Theta one there's no
l2 involved isn't okay so here my I
admit me it seems like here's this
pendulum and if I move this first piece
by a little bit Delta Theta one this
piece also moves and so if you're just
to give us of a straight piece of delta
theta one times l1 moves a little bit
but down here it was like twice as much
so I think that when you do when you
move this little Delta Theta one that
you ought to get even more motion down
here and yet your answers say that's
that's not true
tell me why I what's what's what's
flawed in my reasoning
definition all points move the same so
even though your person okay so you're
saying that we argue that when you have
one virtual displacement or in this case
the rotation Delta Theta one we freeze
all other generalized coordinates that
means we freeze Delta Theta two and
don't let it change Delta Theta two is
measured with respect to the vertical
right so if that moves over Delta Theta
one this whole thing would this angle
here would go from Delta Theta two to
Delta Theta 2 plus Delta Theta one if my
Lodge if my argument is correct but if
for my argument that would have to swing
by Delta Theta one over here as well but
the fact that we freeze theta two in
fact the angle between these two things
has to change this has to open up a
little bit so when this is moving over
this is dropping down so that this point
this whole body only translates so that
whoever described it as just pure
translation that second body that's
another way of saying it so you got to
remember what it means to free you
freezing all the other generalized
coordinates and only allowing the one
you picked a move good all right nice
work
let's we've got some time left so you
have any questions from problem sets
lectures just yeah
in energy routine but there's a Omega
transporter is like in the homework the
last homework I didn't know which Omega
to take whether to take it from the
wheel oh this is the rotating thing with
the katadyn I don't know which Omega
transmitted so should we just talk about
that problem
other people this is the one where you
had the basically the rod and on the end
of the rod was the wheel which was
rotating so this was going around at
some Omega 1 in the Z right and this was
rotating and I think this was like the Z
maybe x and y it was rotating about that
wasn't it mine yeah actually I think I
have it here with its correct definition
so rather than try to here is let's get
the picture
right
and there was an X a Y and a Z and this
was cap Omega and this was Omega 1 and
that's - in mind its direction for this
system right ok then so then we're
trying to compute 1/2 T for this system
1/2 and what we call for the masses here
this was m1 and this is m2 I guess yeah
so this t4 to t1 you don't have a
problem with right do you want it just a
shaft just a rod it's pivoting about its
end 1/2 I about if this is called it Oh
1/2 I I was respect to o ml squared over
3 times that squared you're done that's
the energy of this part this is the
problematic one right the piece of it
so 1/2 I would say mass 2 and does this
have a point they call this point B here
velocity of B dot velocity of B so
that's the 1 f MV squared piece of it
plus a 1/2 Omega dot
H with respect to G for this is mass -
so you have a contribution to the
kinetic energy of this that comes from
its trance from its center of gravity
translating and a contribution from the
rotor rotating with respect to its
center of mass here G here okay and that
would be the expression you use and then
the problem is what's the what Oh Megan
is the trick here right okay this is the
one that had the the concept question I
talked about in class because it came up
with and I hadn't thought about this
about the body coordinates attached to
this are actually rotating with this and
that gets that me that gets messy trying
to figure out what are they how do you
break you're supposed to express the
angular rotation in the body coordinates
right but this angular rotation this one
actually is lined up with this axis and
you could have body coordinates on here
you could have a if this is a Y you
could have a body coordinate X and Z
that rotate with it but this component
would just be still along this axis
right so
the concept question vicente was
basically it is the are the are these
body coordinates XYZ attached to the rod
principal axes for this body and the kit
the complication here is that this body
is rotating and so this X and this Z
don't rotate with that body and so
they're not body fixed coordinates for
that body but in fact they're still
principal coordinates for that body why
is that true
and you can sort of take your clothes
this body is axially symmetric and so at
any instant and time you could say that
you could define a principle coordinate
on this body that is lined up with these
and that so for axially symmetric bodies
you could do that you can do that you
can just say at an instant in time let's
compute the kinetic energy and we have
the we have the rotation of that body
defined in the instantaneous principal
coordinates of the body and so now Omega
for the second body is this in the K
minus omega1 in the J of the XYZ system
rotating with the rod and then you can
all then to complete this what's H
so H with respect to G is I xx I YY eyes
easy times and now this one's rotation
is 0 minus omega1 and cap Omega and I
multiply that times this with the
definition that the first one gives me
the I second one J and so I end up with
3 ep2 pieces the first one is 0 I get an
i YY and then remember these are defined
with respect to the center of mass of
the disk iy y minus iyy omega 1 j plus i
ZZ cap omega k and that would be the
angular momentum for the disk right and
then the kinetic energy the 1/2 omega
dot h you now just have another omega
1/2 and you have a vector 0 minus omega
1 j cap omega k dotted with the H vector
which is your 0i y y omega 1 j and eyes
easy cap omega k yeah and if that one's
negative then
it it will happily fix this one because
it ought to come out looking like Omega
Squared's right and so out of this you
get I why why Omega 1 squared plus eyes
easy cap Omega squared and that's the
second piece and you add it to this beef
different
so um let me
we have a total so let's just talk we
have h with respect to G
a slightly simpler example
so H for the system with respect to the
center is H with respect to G + R G with
respect to the center cross P G right I
can write the angular momentum that way
and first piece we are we know the
second piece our G is in a our hat
direction if you will the P is going
around the circle and so the cross
product that those two gives me a
component what's the direction of the
result so this is our cross say theta
hat if you get a K this ends up again
and this gives you a cave component so
and the eight this one has this one we
write out so this is minus iyy omega 1 j
plus eyes easy kappa mega k plus some
stuff that's in the k agreed and i want
to know the torques required to make
this system do what it's doing
how did i how do I get the torques
required to make the system go around
yeah some of the external torques equals
D H now with respect remember with this
could we win ordinarily Z write that as
an a we'll call it HS respect to o DT
plus velocity usually call it a with
respect to O cross P right in this
system what's the velocity of this piece
this term zero so we have to worry about
it so that some of the external torque
should just be the time derivative of
this angular momentum vector right and D
H then o DT is equal to the partial
derivative with respect to T of H and
I'll write it like this is in the
rotating frame right so this is sturm
that this is the piece from inside the
frame plus this is just a derivative of
a rotating vector Omega cross H and the
issue here is what's the Omega that's
really what this question comes down to
when we did this problem we found that H
has H came from taking the Omega the
vector multiplying it by this and we got
these two pieces and so it started off
with components in the J and K direction
and it came out with components in the J
and K because this was diagonal louis
can't words just so we have principal
axes we came out with this these two
pieces so the angular momentum has a J
component and K component what is actual
now this vector this angular momentum
vector the reason why we have this
second term B is because of a change of
direction of a vector the time this
piece comes from the taking the time
derivatives of the unit vectors in the
problem the time derivatives of the
other stuff in the problem has been
taken care of this by this so this only
deals with the time derivatives of the
unit vectors right so what is the actual
rotation rate of the in the prom this
problem the rate at which things are
changing direction which ones changing
direction
it's this one changing direction now
actually it doesn't give you any
derivative right is this one changing
direction yeah and at what what rotation
rate is it changing direction capital
mega but why not but it but it's not
changing a little Omega is it but you
don't it the math the vector works that
all out for you because this is in the J
direction and all I had this is the same
you just use the same total rotation
vector here and this will have in it the
zero the Omega minus Omega 1 J the plus
Kappa mega K and the parts that you
don't care this dotted this cross with
itself goes to 0 so even though you're
just going ahead and leaving this in
here it doesn't result in anything
because the cross product would cross
product with itself gives you nothing so
the only piece that actually contributes
nonzero contribution to this answer is
this crossed with the pieces in here so
just so when you're d28 avec ters
remember the original formula the
original formula is the derivative of
the vector in the rotating frame is its
magnitude getting more or less plus the
just the rotation rate cross with the
original vector and the pieces that are
common just fall out the piece of this
that is due to its own own rotation
doesn't enter into it this rotation
doesn't contribute to that D by DT of
the rotation just works out for it yeah
I mean if this one is going in the K ah
then you didn't have the big Omega term
because the actual thing is that that
the big Omega would be taken into
account when looking at the first if
this one also had some K rotation in
addition relative to here we'll call it
Omega 2 in the K direction right then
what's the total rotation rate in the K
direction for the disk ads cap Omega 2
Omega 2 and you'd have its total K
directed rotation right and if you did
that you'd end up in here with a mega
plus and make Kappa Omega plus Omega 2
okay and when you came out but when you
came over to do the the time derivative
you just leave put leave all those
things in there and the ones that you
don't care about it will just cancel out
because their cross products with
themselves
oh yeah well the cap Omega appears in
this piece but this goes to K we just
that we did a particular problem I'm not
trying to prove this in general though
there's probably a way to do that this
problem this term is in the K direction
and therefore it that K hat does not
change direction with time therefore the
dhdt of this piece goes to zero so we
only had to deal with this part in
taking the time derivative it dealt with
the changes in direction it's only the
changes in direction that the Omega
cross something matters right okay good
question anybody something else recent
problems
somebody in the last class asked about
ask questions about this thing that
bring anything to memory I see some
grimaces what troubled you about that
problem what troubled the last group
about that problem was the posted
solution they didn't understand the
posted solution so I ran through one
other way I went I showed why the posted
solution works the way it does
well one confusion I have to his
promises at the spring for the wheel
mass one that serves placements know
Newton's third being what it is should
it also exert some force on a large base
mass as well so you should take that
into account for the total displacement
caused by Springs heard you know big
nasty are you talking about not
computing just beginning equations of
motion or computing generalized forces
or what the context yes when you're
computing your equations of motion you
have to take into account the larger
mass both the displacements of the
spring gets attached to em almonds as
well as V yeah if you're doing this by
the direct method you do have you have
to figure that out
so the here's a way of doing it this is
a way that I think the the way that the
student just read off his paper so I
said let's let's talk about the forces
in the X direction on the main mass okay
well that's that's mass one times its
acceleration must be equal to all the
external forces this is minus KX minus
BX dot this is minus the X component of
the spring force minus the X component
of the friction force from the wheel
minus the X component of any normal
force from the wheel and I do the same
thing for the second mass m2
the total forces on it must be equal its
mass times its acceleration well it's
acceleration I'm doing this just again
in the X direction its acceleration in
the X
is the main mass X double dot which it's
sitting on B and the X component of the
relative coordinate x1 double dot this
is the total acceleration in the X
direction of the second mass and the
total forces on that second mass are
signs have changed internal force
internal force internal force plus the
force that was applied actually adheres
written here's that external force that
was applied to that wheel if you take
these two equations to just add them
together all will the internal forces
drop out said plus FX minus FX all of
those drop out and you end up with an
expression it says this is a system the
total external forces on the system in
the X direction must be equal to the
total mass of the system times the
acceleration of its center of mass right
that's what Newton said well the
acceleration of the center of mass is
the sum of the individual pieces times
their individual accelerations some of
the the total mass times the cellar
ation of the center of mass is equal to
the sum of the individual masses times
their individual accelerations mass 1
its acceleration mass 2 its acceleration
due to its local coordinate plus its
acceleration due to the main mass
acceleration and all of that's got to be
equal to the external forces which are
now only minus KX minus BX dot and plus
F and this term here this stuff all
including this these three MX double dot
terms all added together is the same
thing as a total mass times the
acceleration of the center of mass which
is somewhere but but that's a completely
JIT legitimate
equation for this system and it involves
both masses both coordinates so you this
one here would just be some X 1 double
dot like time to co-sign fee or a sign
fee or something like no no there's
still has to be too but that I've just
shown you a way of getting at one of
them without ever solving for the
internal forces but by just realizing
that if I do separate them that Newton's
third law with all the internal ones
will cancel want to add the two pieces
together I still have to get a second
equation where would you get it
yeah you want to do something more you
don't have to salt you want to don't
want to have to solve for any of these
any of these internal forces that you
don't know right so the spring force you
can know because it is a minus K times
the coordinate that you have to use
minus K x1 so I would go in here and I'd
say maybe the what's the sum of the
torques about that point perhaps and
no-slip so these terms that get voids
having to deal with any of these forces
the real force acting on it will force
you have to deal with that and the minus
K x1 force you need it comes into your
equation of motion but if you do this
you're going to have one little if you
do that particular approach it has one
problematic Tara it's not terrible but
you have to remember to deal with it is
that the sum of the X torques about that
one point we'll call a is d H a DT plus
V a o cross P right or I gave you an
equation yesterday this is easier to do
usually if you do d hg dt plus r g with
respect to a cross the mass times the
acceleration of G with respect to O this
would be the second mass m2 you can you
can drive it's about two about three
lines you can prove that this statements
the same as that this one turns out this
one's less work and the reason that this
one's more work is this term always
cancels out cancels out with a piece
that is generated when you do this
calculation but you know how messy this
stuff gets you got all these unit
vectors run around and cosine Thetas and
nine days it's a lot of work to get this
space and it's twice the work because
you have to go in and find the piece
that cancels it in here so if you
actually I sat down about a week ago and
said there's got to be a way to get rid
of this thing and there is and it comes
out like this
now there's no pieces that cancel I you
can't you cancelled out in the proof and
get this piece to go away and you do it
this you're left with this so this is
the distance from your point to the
center of mass in this case is just R
and the only thing you have to calculate
is the acceleration of the center of
mass which is capital X double dot plus
x1 double dot yard you know that so this
is vastly easier to do
center mass again [ __ ] lost [ __ ]
finally because you're trying cuz you're
doing it around point a is what gets you
into this mess if you're doing it as
soon as you work with respect if you're
working with G in the center of mass
then this is V G cross V G which is
always zero this has a V G in it so
that's the reason we like to work around
centers of mass but we don't do centers
of mass when it causes this to have a
whole bunch of external things we don't
know thanks yes